do you plan to work on any more graphic
design projects oh I've work on them all
the time on graphic design people come
to me and ask me to do logos quite often
because I've done quite a lot of logos
and something that are quite good if you
look on micro to dot info side which is
a bit out today because I've done lots
of them sense that I it's quite
interesting logos because you you have a
problem to solve something that looks
good but also try to indicate some
aspect of the organization you're trying
to represent with the letters and things
that net that nature and so in the case
of aliens France Tallahassee aft alley I
got the a there's blue the f is white
and the t is red and so it's it's
possible to do this so that it you've
got the French flag in there so that's
my most recent rather satisfying design
and I always like to have a little
design of that kind in there and this a
little bit like science as well you know
you have a problem you work it out
within a certain sort of restricted set
of approaches to doing this so that's
yeah lots of nothing but I also this
book as i told you is coming out of
Christmas in Japan and I so much enjoyed
working with my family to pull this book
together and developing an experience
with Photoshop transferring drawings to
sort of printed sort of format so that
it could be published and that was
pretty good trouble as I don't have
enough time because I'm spending a lot
of time answering these questions